This is the market sophistication worksheet
for chapter 3 of breakthrough
advertising and just to go over sort of
the idea here is when you're doing work around
Market sophistication, you're really looking at
what your competition is doing in the
market. So what messages are are they
putting in the minds of your
prospects and customers? What are
the different strategies strategies and
tactics that they're using?
And so this is this is really a two-part exercise. So the
first part is just looking at
who else is marketing to your
your customers or the the people that
you want to be your customers. So, you know here in space
below list the name of your product and and the
the problem that you're product solves and
then look at what other competitors are
trying to solve a similar problem. So the first
step is just take one of your products get
you're just very clear on the
specific problem that solves.
and then
in this part, we're listing.
The competitors who are selling the same product as you so
that's what goes here. But then here
it's a little bit of a different approach where you're listing
competitors that are solving the same problem as
you so this could be a
different product. And the reason you want to do that is if somebody's
trying to solve the same problem as you but
they're using a different product there may be things that you
can learn from the way that they're talking about the the problem the
way they're describing the problem and the way they describe the
opportunity. But but these are all these are
all messages that are competing for the
Mind share of your market. So once you've done a little
bit of work around similar products similar messaging then
you can go into the second
exercise.
You're based on your competitive research you
then write down what stage of
sophistication you believe your Market to be in and
then based on that stage. You know, you look
here and here's your prescription.
And you know, so if you if you come to
to realize that well, I'm in a stage
three. So my prospects they've they've heard everything like
they're tired. They don't believe the marketing
messages. They don't believe the promises anymore. Then
you know that what you need to do to stand out
is do some work around a mechanism
and we talk about that. There's an exercise
later on on how to find a
unique mechanism for your product. So
so this is this is just part of a slow
process to to get clearly on
who else is kind of
fighting for the attention of your market. And so this is Market sophistication.